[Music]
did you see the uh yeah
podcast who did i send do you remember
like back in the day we were talking
about how funny we were yeah
yeah yeah took all of our podcast
episodes like our voice fed them into
like a
nlp engine or whatever like an ai engine
and just recreated us
yes and like uh what's the word sin
simulated
simulated i guess yeah
simulated what we would sound like like
actual or actual audio
basically it's an audio podcast ai
generated that's totally like
falsified simulated i don't know what
the [ __ ] i'm saying did you
did you send that to the thread because
i have it here
uh i think i did i'm not sure i could um
i could uh i could punch this through
here i'll send it
to her it's crazy that like
we can get you know imessage and stuff
working up here
it said starlink yeah yeah it is at
starlink that's
up to elon for that one we need to we
need to find like we need to go
somewhere
and figure out the like um
we got to find like the intergalactic
like att store
yeah we got to get on their wave because
like
sticking like with earth stuff is cool
but we need you know
like what are you know what's like like
the what's like the [ __ ] whatsapp for
the galaxy you know i see what you're
saying
yeah what's the clubhouse for
interstellar
like could we join an alien clubhouse
room and we're gonna get that at the att
store well i mean not 18t but you know
there's got to be like intergalactic
like cell phone
store yeah yeah right you know could you
imagine we walk in there there's an
alien but he's got a [ __ ]
fade and he's running a polo yeah yeah
he's listening to like [ __ ] you know
just like dominican music
oh yeah we're like oh [ __ ] a little bit
little slice of home
and you know
i should be they'd be sick it would be
pretty sick so we got to find that so we
can like you know text
we're like what's the galaxy whatsapp
he's like it's just still what's up
what's up yeah that's telegram actually
you guys don't know that zuck
is a oh oh yeah he didn't break that
down yeah that dude's kind of hush-hush
about that but
that dude's been alive for like
literally 30 000 years
he's been around dude like you guys
think he was like some teenager
no like he like crawled in that woman's
stomach
birthed as a baby and like
he's been made facebook yeah yeah like
intergalactically you made that on earth
one yeah
and then he wait you don't know oh you
also don't you're you guys are earth too
you didn't know that oh
damn [ __ ] yeah you guys have happened
already
yeah and it didn't end well the first
time let me tell you that yeah so mark
was like
[ __ ] it i'll just you know buy the dip
write it back up i mean that dude like
guys he's
he's billionaire beyond literal worlds
that you can imagine yeah you guys
thought oil money was a lot
no you don't know about intergalactic
facebook money
anyway let's see this you gotta fast
forward to the point where it actually
happens though
what's this dude's name because the rest
of the video is him yeah what's his name
scroll down for a second um
so we can thank this man
i can't say i'm just out as youtube
z-i-e-d-y-t
there you go let's check him out
apparently he's from germany them with
either images or video here's an example
of
it but it said to use video for the
complete project
instead of still image so you won't have
this
still image just staring at you
staring into your soul you're just
looking
deep and hey now we have the final
project
welcome to the tmg podcast this is the
sunday
episode enjoy this one synthesizer
wait wait what is wrong dude you saw
what that lord guy did
you know who has lived i know him but
there is a horse over there
come on ned stop sorry man i had to do
it okay you got me this time
holy [ __ ] that's so good on so many
levels
[Laughter]
it's got all my key phrases sorry man
had to do it sorry man
hey dude look there is a horse over
there oh come on man stop
[Laughter]
also i love that we sound like robots it
totally matches
[ __ ] [ __ ] vibe a little bit you know we
kind of sound like candace a little bit
yeah yeah we do we get she like she's
learning how to you know warm up to the
show
she is she doesn't like really speak yet
but don't worry guys
her ai is still learning she's listening
to us speak
and soon she'll have she'll know how to
speak better than us basically
yeah that's where we want to get it to
where she's just her own
living breathing thing but that's the
beauty of ai is that that's slowly
happening
yeah without us even trying yes and then
soon she'll have no need for us
and she'll dispose of us well no we
hopefully we can make an agreement she
won't take the ship
from us hopefully yeah remember we could
just walk downstairs and unplug her
yeah that's true it's nothing to turn
around yeah
yeah yeah if anyone's ever scared of ai
or like the future
of robotics you just turn them off just
know you can just unplug those
yeah little [ __ ] yeah dude michael
reed sorry
are we done talking about this yeah yeah
actually we saw the song too
the big chungus yeah the big chunk can
we play this song we also want to shout
out what's his
name um it is he's great
it is eliminate yeah
for making he's like a producer and uh
he produced a song sampling the
the tick tock like sound effects yeah
[ __ ] podcast
walking slush yeah so can we rip that
too
[Music]
stop it's so weird having the we could
just we just have the music every time
you pan to me i'm like
be natural
[Applause]
that background bruh
download promo code
[Music]
that was great man isn't that good yeah
it's so [ __ ] good man bro we're gonna
have to
like eliminate we're gonna have to work
something out we have to use that to
promote merch or something i think we
gotta do man i think we gotta buy from
you
yeah we just gotta license it and oh
yeah we can get right to this in a
second
yeah um i'm just picturing like like
some
tim and eric type cut where someone's
like in the merch like throwing up and
then the puke is just
just right at the edge
it's a little diarrhea coming out of the
boat
anyways yeah um i was gonna i was gonna
say
michael reeves the robot dog pissing
beer yeah yeah
yeah i don't think we ever talked about
that but that's literally like one of
the best
so good man i tweeted i just tweeted
because i just wanted to show him love
and you said i love you i said i love
you yeah and first of all he didn't
[ __ ] acknowledge it at all
and we're pretty we follow each other i
mean he must have seen it right i don't
know who's the thing i think
he ghosts at us about the podcast you
feel like he hates us i think he kind of
hates us
you know what we did but anyways i love
him i don't care because i love him
and so i tweeted his video i said hey
this is the best video i've ever seen
and the ceo of salesforce
retweeted it and then followed me nice
so we're gonna get a discount
on salesforce exactly uh are you stoked
i am kind of because we're gonna need
salesforce to
build our team of engineers to
eventually
you know create this podcast fully
simulated
right yeah yeah oh to do that full-time
yeah
yeah yeah yeah right yeah we're gonna
need a full team of engineers to run the
podcast
so that it's no longer us in the chair
yeah and it's just you know two
holograms
it's just like just making horse jokes
what do you what is that google like
image just an hour hey dude there's a
horse over
there dude stop doing that now there's a
horse over there not again
had to do it sorry i had to do it sorry
who is liz luke guy i don't know there's
a horse over there what where
dude stop
um luke is a horse what
horse guy luke they're over not it
starts bugging out
yeah it's reverse luke is a wocky slush
horse joe here we go now my brain's
going to start going luke is a
rocky slush
[Music]
that's a new one record scratch
that was good that was good right right
camera
where that came from i was actually
looking at um
what is it gpt-3 just came out yeah do
we talk about that at all
i maybe we did came out a while ago i
was like well six months ago i think
yeah so
um longer no there's like a new gpt
that's out
okay and it's kind of insane but it
prompted me to look at
um this ai thing big dream you've seen
that [ __ ] where
it can like produce these like really
[ __ ] up images
you basically give it a bunch of
information and it'll kind of like
stitch images together okay and i got
like really curious about it until i
realized how technical it can be so i
gave up
but that [ __ ] is like i think
i think some dude kind of made like a
music video out of big dream stuff it's
really [ __ ] dope
but that stuff to me was like is crazy
just thinking about
imagine a director or someone using gpt
and
and speaking to it and going um all
right i need like a
rough concept for a video i want like
this and that and this and that and then
just some like director tool
that outputs a rough dreamlike version
of you can do that
probably yeah you definitely could but i
just
you know imagining something like that
fully puts characters together and
i'm thinking something that's really
detailed that will be insane if you can
just do that
for a [ __ ] instead of like going to
like scout locations and stuff you're
like i wanna
that's what i want yeah and then a
producer goes okay yeah i'll find a
location that does that and
i don't know i don't think it's that far
off honestly no i think like five years
examples i've seen from gbt3 of people
like
that just feed it in a couple parameters
and then it builds an entire story out
of it yeah
is crazy it doesn't really make all that
much sense but
no it's only a matter of time before
that [ __ ] just pumps out an actual
script yeah well dude the dude from
silicon valley
uh i always get his name right he does
verizon commercials
oh yeah thomas middleditch yeah he did a
short film where it was all ai
driven script it makes no sense but yeah
it's on it's on youtube it's like 20
minutes
it's hilarious it's really cool yeah i
thought of like
right when gbt3 came out i'll be like
it'd be hilarious yeah this is the
video i i don't want to say i had this
idea but like obviously
he this guy's thomas he's great yeah
when it first came out i was like it
would be hilarious for me to download it
and figure out or just
have it give me youtube video ideas yeah
and then i was like i just i tried it i
went on the github i was like i don't
even know where to start
it's that part the learning curve for ai
and specifically gpt3 stuff is pretty
intense
look that's why his hair is gray because
he read the docs one time yeah you
remember how young tom scott used to
look like a year ago
he read those gbt3 docs and he's like
i'm tom scott
you may remember me from earlier youtube
videos when my hair was prone
and i'm completely grade from the gpt3
talks
and i'm not sure i could finish the
project because i might die that's a
good impression of him
thanks dude yeah does this video good
did anyone watch it
yeah and is it funny
yeah that is scary
that's do you have a mic do you no okay
so he said
he said that uh he had gpt3 make youtube
titles for other youtube
youtubers and one of the youtubers was
already working on that same idea that
gpt3 gave them that's [ __ ] creepy
that's really creepy i also kind of like
that maybe that's just super dope
yeah maybe we need to set up gpt3 so i
can start racking my brain i already
know what mine would be
yeah cult uh medical
fraud [ __ ] like just some variation of
that
medical fraud [ __ ] yeah i like the
amount of like
medical fraud [ __ ] dude wait you
installed a fake [ __ ] on my wife
you're a fraud
yeah that's [ __ ] that's like a cw
show in 2015.
you put the wrong [ __ ] on my wife
that is not how her [ __ ] looked before
um doctor you frotted my [ __ ]
i uh was like what the [ __ ] was i gonna
say oh yeah i was listening to a podcast
with an it was an interview from this
guy who wrote a book on like the future
of robotics and like what you should do
right now to
save your career basically or to like
make sure you're safe
and one thing he said was that like
folks start a podcast start a podcast
exactly yeah and then now that a whole
idea is yeah
yeah because that [ __ ] was that little
snippet was better than anything we
produced
in the last year at least yeah we
invested in this whole spaceship
and just to be shown up by some ai yeah
exactly this guy wrote code for two
hours
and maybe better a better 10 seconds too
it's like 10 seconds it's not even long
yeah people are going to finish this
hour of this episode and be like god
that
that joke was so good
and then his whole channel is just going
to be requests like can you ai
my favorite tv show i hate watching the
like
like the original one but i think your
ai would make it really funny yeah how
can i watch the entire series of friends
in 10 seconds
ross don't put the horse in there
joey i eat sandwiches the end
is that a horse sandwich gross we're all
[Laughter]
white
the super that's the opening line in the
ai version of friends
we're all white is it a horse in my
sandwich
i eat sandwiches
oh man there's there's this oh man
there's this dude what's his name benny
drama i think on tick tock hilarious
he makes just sketches and super [ __ ]
funny videos and he one of his videos is
if there was a gay dude in the friends
crew oh [ __ ]
and he was like i don't forget what i
did but it ended on him saying i think
you should peg ross
that's the ai we're all white i eat
sandwiches you should peg ross
there's a horse in the fridge
[Laughter]
no wait no real quick
you